we've got the health secretary joining
us now from central london hello to you
mr hancock thanks for joining us
uh this morning it's a bit of a role
reversal this morning isn't it it's
normally
that i'm in the studio and you're at
home but hey
let's let's give it a go should we um
the prime minister
how is he this morning is he well
yeah he's well he's absolutely full of
beans uh
and uh he he was in close contact with
lee anderson the mp for ashfield last
week
and when lee anderson
felt a bit unwell he applied for a test
he got that test result back
within the same day
and and of course the same rules apply
to all of us
and so the prime minister is
self-isolating because he was asked to
buy nhs test and trace
sure same rules apply for to all of us
why they're not wearing masks in that
photograph
uh well they are uh they're socially
distanced
um and the critical thing is of course
as prime minister you do
uh you do meet people and he'll be i've
got
no doubt driving things forwards this
week
by zoom but the thing is that when you
are in
in close contact with somebody then you
do need to
self-isolate if they test a positive
and that's exactly what the prime
minister's done
you also need to wear a mask when you're
in close contact with people especially
indoors
don't you and they're not and what's
happened
well there are there are of course
covered secure guidelines
for how you operate at work and this is
true
in downing street or in any other work
environment
and then if you test positive it's
really good that the test result came
back
so quickly that is now happening in the
majority of cases
and that's good we've brought those test
turnaround times down
and then contact tracing working
effectively
got in contact with the prime minister
so
that is this is how the system uh ought
to operate
and then obviously the both uh lee
anderson
and the prime minister uh following
those rules and in fact
you mentioned just on the bulletin then
you know we're expanding this testing
capacity further we've built
half
we're going to more than double that
health secretary we're coming to that
we're coming to that why on earth are
they not wearing a mask
as a result our prime minister is
incapacitated on what could be one of
the most
important weeks ever for brexit they
should
be wearing masks you know that i know
that
why are they not doing it well there's
covered secure guidelines in any
workplace and
what i'd say is actually i have
absolutely no doubt that the prime
minister will be able to
uh to to drive the agenda forward and
communicate with the public uh in the
way that he does
normally but just differently because
it'll be by
by uh by video conference and uh
and um and not face to face because he's
self-isolating
okay majority of times i see the prime
minister i
well the majority of times i see the
prime minister i see him by zoom
actually
and that's effective because we can have
the meeting and
i can stay in in my office and he stays
in
number 10 but i did see him i saw him a
couple of times last week
before he saw mr
mr anderson for instance in the house of
commons chamber where
uh i was for pmq's last week um
and masks are there are required outside
of the chamber but not in it so there's
covert secure guidelines in all
workplaces
okay um do you wear a mask when you're
in number 10 health secretary
uh not always no because the covert
secure guidelines for that building
don't require it at all times well it's
it's according to the rules that are set
out for each workplace in the whole
country so different workplaces
have different rules according to what
is appropriate
there and you'll know that from
uh from your work and
and everybody else you know one of the
things that we've done is put in place
but you know what
those guidelines health secretary my
boss didn't nearly die from covert
19. my boss is not in a position where
he now has to self-isolate again for two
weeks
because um he's coming into contact with
somebody who's got covid
19. i'm sure my viewers will make up
their own minds this morning you said
that the prime minister
will be able to do uh his job just as
effectively what if he needs to
hop on the eurostar and have a chat with
our european friends
as as you always call them he can't do
that
so his position is limited because they
didn't wear a piece of cloth covering
their face
well uh the firstly it's lord frost
who's gone to brussels
and is our chief negotiator and i'm sure
that if the prime minister needs to
speak to
anybody in europe then he'll be able to
do that by
zoom and or by one of many other
uh different types of video conferencing
that's available
and so he will i absolutely no doubt be
driving forward the
agenda uh in the way that he uh in the
way that he normally does and
you know there's a packed agenda
expanding the testing i've talked about
uh also driving forward the search for a
vaccine and you'll have heard the news
this morning that we're starting the
clinical trials of another vaccine
coming to that
here in the uk okay let me drive the
agenda this morning health secretary if
you don't mind we'll come to all of that
we're still talking about brexit at the
moment fishermen and farmers
some of those who had most hope to
benefit from brexit are less
and less likely to unless there is
a deal um doesn't look where we are at
the moment
as if that deal is forthcoming does it
well as i say lord frost is going to
brussels this week
to uh work with the europeans i'm
i i i've absolutely
no doubt that he is the best possible
person to carry out these negotiations
for
uh for this country uh and our red lines
haven't changed
and we're preparing for whatever the
outcome is
of course our preference is uh to get a
deal and that is
open to the to the europeans if they
choose to
to make the progress that's needed
yeah president-elect joe biden um is not
a fan
of brexit uh we need a deal
with the us if we don't get a deal with
europe how are we going to placate him
well actually the relationship with
president-elect
biden and the prime minister has started
off very strongly on the front foot
you know the prime minister was the
first european leader
that the president-elect called and we
have very very close
close ties that you know transcend any
presidency
um between the countries and very close
interests you know and and
i know that they uh that they talked
about
working together on climate change a
really important priority
of the prime minister and of the
president-elect working
together of course tackling coronavirus
together and how we can do that and
on a wide range of subjects we have very
close interest with the united states
and i know that the relationship between
the president-elect and the prime
minister started off on
on very much on the front foot
okay uh president trump still hanging on
in there
president-elect biden has described him
as an embarrassment and it won't help
his legacy what do you think
well i'm absolutely not going to get
into it into the domestic politics of
america
there's enough to be getting on with
with the domestic politics of the uk
um and but what we are doing is looking
forward very much to working with the
incoming
biden administration and as i said on
on you know so many big topics where we
need to work
uh together and where the
the the agenda of this government for
instance on climate change
with cop 26 coming up next year you've
mentioned so closely allied with the
agenda of the i
yeah it's important you see are you i'm
completely comfortable
with that absolutely we've done it we've
done it we'll i'm sure we'll come back
to it and it's not really your brief and
we need to come on to your brief in just
a second
i'm just checking whether you are
completely comfortable
with the way the leader of the free
world
is behaving himself over the last 48
hours particularly
well i've got absolutely nothing to say
about that what i
what i'm doing is really looking forward
and we're very very positive about the
uh
uh about the incoming biden
administration
you know for instance on my area um he
is committed to engaging with and
reforming the international
health system the world health
organization rather than
leaving it i think that's really
positive that's the position the uk has
taken throughout this we need reform
but we need to be in there making those
reforms rather than walking away and
so i'm really looking forward personally
to working with the uh
biden administration too i'm surprised
yeah okay i'm surprised that you have
nothing to say
about a president who is openly
via twitter um stoking up hostility in
his own country
but let me ask you about the vaccine um
roll out um
and mega labs let me put both of those
into
one with both of them i'm guessing that
means that christmas is back on
well we're absolutely working to make
christmas
as normal as possible in fact we're
working with the devolved
administrations to try to get a set of
a set of rules set of arrangements for
christmas that can work across the whole
of the uk because so many people have
family in different parts of the
of the uk the expansion of testing
may be able to help to deliver on that
in terms of the vaccine
and the uh obviously we're ready and
working hard to
roll out the vaccine it will be a huge
administrative challenge
and even on the even if that comes
through as fast as it
possibly could um the the majority of
people
will be we'd expect to be vaccinating in
the new year
even if we do manage to make progress uh
this year but you've got to remember on
the vaccine that we are not there
yet we don't yet have a vaccine signed
off so i understand the excitement and
the hope
the hope value of the vaccine it's
really fantastic
but we are not there yet but on testing
we are there
we're rolling out the mass testing right
now and we're doubling the capacity of
the
labs over the next few months we've got
that half a million capacity which we've
built up from
scratch you know essentially built a
british diagnostics industry
and as you can see from uh from
lee anderson the mp for ashfield we now
get those rapid turnaround times too for
the majority of people
okay um i wonder what you'll miss most
about
dominic cummings
well i've worked very closely with him
and um
you know he's he's he's he's been very
effective at driving things forward but
uh you know i've i look forward to
uh to keeping that pace
you know that incredible pace that we've
had to drive
through this government especially
during the pandemic
and i can't wait till the day that we've
been able to
crack the pandemic get life back to
normal
and then uh pick up where we left off
with the leveling up agenda which is so
important that we were elected on you
know almost a year ago we were having
these discussions a year ago it was an
election campaign and we were talking
about leveling up
across this country and that matters
enormously to me
and i know that it's something that
really matters to
to people right across the country so i
can't wait to be able to
be uh you know to have the pandemic
um sorted life as back to normal as
possible and really pushing forward on
on the leveling up agenda okay not
missing much about him then
let me just let you have the opportunity
to once more
uh offer your view on donald trump he's
tweeted
we won't let a rigged election steal our
country
that was the leader of the third world
we'd be going mad
i'm concentrating on getting a vaccine
over the line
delivering mass testing getting life
back to normal for people
making sure that people can can have
those you know those those
loving interactions that make us human
and making life worth living uh and that
have been put on hold because of this
pandemic i i've really got enough to
deal with without having to respond to
every single one of uh president trump's
tweets
okay and uh if he's still in power he
certainly will be
on the first of january you haven't done
a deal with the european union you're
very happy
for uh whoever i don't know
to uh maybe um i don't know whoever it
might be
to do a deal with president trump
i'm totally sorry i didn't really
understand the question but uh
if it was about the first time no no i
completely understand
my question is if my question is if we
haven't
done a deal with the european union uh
by the 31st
of december we need to start looking at
doing deals with others around the world
like the united states of america would
you be happy for
our government to be doing a deal with a
man who who says an election has been
rigged
oh i see um well firstly we are
absolutely ready for any outcome
we'd prefer obviously to leave with a
deal
but our red lines haven't changed and
we're ready for any outcome
and then of course i'm keen that we do a
trade deal with the united states um and
um that that's completely irrespective
of who's in the white house and i think
it would be
i think that would be good for both the
uk and for the
for the united states now i believe in
free trade i know that free trade
increases prosperity
and so i hope that we can do trade deals
around the world in the same way that
we've already
done a trade deal with with japan and
there's i'm sure many many more to come